不敢露凉
没文化,话也说不清楚
但是我想做短视频,我该怎么办
按照一旦这种情况,我都会骂回去的
但是最近我真的看了
好多私信
就真的很有人特别难
特别难
所以他们希望我帮忙他
我就想了想,不说这样
给他出几个主意吧
就是不敢露凉
然后说话也不会说
然后也被我什么文化
但我还想做短视频,怎么办呢
给大家介绍几个方法
第一个方法是不需要你做点的
就是如果你有手机
然后你可以读评
那你就会这样做
比如说九里一早
你就可以读评
然后
打开一个计算器
那次到我给大家出主意啊
比如说你的公司是五千五千
然后呢
可能配上文案,发工资的一天
然后剪去一千五
是什么呢,等于房租
房租
剪去
我不知道房多少钱
或是费,可能是一千
剪去哪一份钱
比如说
五百
就是这样的吧
因为
就是
你可以忘记一周一,一周一,一周一,一周一,一周一,一周一,一
剪到最后的时候可能
比如说
一周一,一周一,一周一,一周一,一周一,一周一,一周一
可能最后,你没有多少钱呢
但这个时候
你说我可能要买一个什么东西,结果买不了
能理解我意思吗
这时候不用说啊
这是五文字
剪去房租,剪去
第2号费
剪去
大家想买个什么东西
结果,但是真的买不了了
或者
这是情况
然后配上文案
成年的崩溃
就在发工资的一天
对吧,就你不说了我两个人
然后呢
你也不说说话的,文字读形就会了
还有的类似的话,如果你有经理的话,比如像这种背望路也可以
在上了可以打资
打资可以这么写
比如说
其实我特别想跟你说
然后请问一下
然后把那个字全部在删掉
最后,有着一句
祝你幸福
配上医院
这种其实你会有很多的想法
你也可以取财资生活
对吧,就是包括你的日常对话呀生活的
都可以动作路平的完成的
这是不需要
漏了点,不需要受害的
然后大家稍微高级一点的吧
比如说
我其实是我推荐大家去做的
还是要有一些文化的,就是找些书来读
真的可以改变你的
生活的一些书
尤其是一些倡修的经典的书,比如像昌老寶电子
对吧,或者是
被讨厌的武器啊,都这些书
真的是人看
看的时候,真的是好好看,不着急,不要看别的东西
也不用考虑怎么拍东西
就看到一段话的时候,你特别特别有感触的时候,特别特别特别感触
对,对这句子特别感触的时候
不要躲了,一定是特别感触的时候不要躲了
然后他固定住,那么手机相机
对着他拍手
对他拍手,他答应什么的也好了,我们拍手
找一个比赢光笔,然后在那个
让你特别感觉那种话里面
慢慢的花鞋
花鞋那种种,一定要有那个笔
滑过书的那种
那个杀杀的声音
但是呢,这个时候各位你要注意点,吃什么,就是你在花鞋的时候
一定要明白,你不是在花字
你是在花顾名
是花生活的感受,一定要有,因为你当时有感觉嘛,所以你得花的时候
虽然你得花字,但是哪个一定像的时候
我是你生活的感受是不明,然后放一段思语的语员
这样的话呢,你提拔视频拍了,同时你会躲得点舒服
这里边还是有一个体育,就是你可以通过卖书来的赚钱的
第三个就是稍微高级一点的,大家如果
会看一些电影的话,那你就知道有些电影的,台词是非常非常棒的,就有些时候我们看电影
我就有诱话说是,你去看电影的时候,你是不需要寄别寄的
但是你那里面的话,可以让你寄一辈子
对吧,所以有些电影台词是非常非常棒的,比如说它像一条狗哎
就这次这样的一些经历的对话,或者什么
然后你把你的那个屏幕变成黑色的,稍微有点白亮,有一点白糟音
就是电影上的那个白糟音,整个屏幕都是黑的,不需要画面
然后只把那个原声扣出来
然后再有一段字
那个字就会电影的字一样打出来,是在中间也好在下面也好,然后配到那个那个电影的原声
这种话特别经历的一个话,给我们的猫猫意思吗?就是整个画面是不放的
只是把那个经历的台词拿出来,然后原声放出来,然后一段次导的下面或者打造
今年都会,这种视频特别适合放在晚上
我给大家出几个主意啊,你看,你不需要
弱点,你也不需要说话,你也不需要什么文化
但是如果你真的愿意有心去体愿生活
你说一定可以拍好视频的
加油